الى جدل اخر هذا الصباح
اكدت مجموعه ام بي سي ان مسلسل معاويه ما
زال قيد التحضير انتاجيا وفنيا وسيتم
الاعلان عن موعد عرضهم بمجرد ان يصبح
جاهزا ام بي سي اعلنت في بيان لها ان
الخطابات المفبركه التي يتم تداولها عبر
بعض منصات التواصل ووسائل الاعلام على
انها صادره من المجموعه حول مسلسل معاويه
ليس لها اي اساس من الصحه
مجموعه ام بي سي اوضحتنا الخطابات التي
تحمل شعاراتها هي خطابات مزوره ولا اساس
لها من الصحه وتنتحل صفه المجموعه مؤكده
ان كل من يتناقلها بقسط او غير قصد سيضع
نفسه تحت طائله المساءله القانونيه ام بي
سي شددت على ان البيانات متعلقه بالمجموعه
هي التي تصدر رسميا وتوزع عبر مكتبها
الاعلامي من مقرها الرئيسي وان المصدر
الوحيد الموثوق للمعلومات المتعلقه
بانتاجات المجموعه هو شاشتها ومنصاتها
وصفحاتها الرسميه